[Music]
yeah I've been very very grateful with
Harper one they just they're really and
look they published my favorite book of
all time The Alchemist yeah you know so
like to walk in there obviously that
poster then one day like my poster is
gonna be by it you know like it's it's
pretty special it's a crazy thing when
you go to the publishing offices and you
see the cover of your book or you see it
like on the wall with these other
authors that you Revere and yeah right
over the years yeah there's something
really magical and special about that it
really is I remember just walking into
public like when I was going to you know
like cuz I've written other books as
well like a novel so forth and going
with my agent to Simon & Schuster Random
House HarperCollins all these like these
are I grew up reading and knowing these
names had to be there and it's just
offices full of nothing but books right
it's beautiful and as a writer to be
there you know it's it's what you dream
of yeah right it's cool also because you
went from this self-publishing
phenomenon into traditional publishing
rather than the other way around like a
lot of people there they'll do their
initial books in a traditional manner
and then when they develop an audience
then they'll self publish but for you to
have this kind of viral phenomenon
almost eight years ago right yeah that
with a you know a sort of truncated
limited version of the book and then to
develop it with a traditional publisher
is interesting yeah it's not something I
planned on you know like when I did the
original version it was tiny right I
mean but I added with an axe I cut out
90% what I wrote right and I put it out
and I didn't think I was and I've said
this enough you know like I really
didn't think I was gonna signing copies
like I was an unknown writer you know I
was just a Silicon Valley guy but a book
I love yourself like your life depends
on it like look I failed but look I
learned to love myself so life's great
and and it took off that thing took off
insanely changed my life like showed me
just a power of my words well let's back
it up a little bit because it kind of
began
with our mutual friend James all teacher
who's actually coming here tomorrow and
you saw him this morning
randomly are ya yeah yeah and I promised
to him that I would actually write write
it and if he and if he like to have a
publish it otherwise it never would have
I was didn't it began like you you had
as you say in the book like you gave you
got up on stage at a conference and had
kind of an epiphany and made this
decision to share openly and honestly
about what was really going on with you
in front of us yeah a group of CEOs and
the like senators Congress people
Pentagon officials and CEOs and media
types and I was given two minutes to
talk give a talk call if I could do
anything and other people were doing
this talk to and I had the you know how
to talk prepared and and I got up and
out like right before God I'm like this
doesn't feel right this doesn't feel
right and I kind of like I don't want to
do I'm gonna share just share with them
what changed my life this past summer or
fall and for two minutes I just rambled
about how I changed my life I learned to
love myself I would say saved me changed
my life how you know like it literally
transforms everything and I got off the
stage thinking okay dude that was that
that was insane what did you just do
like I was trying not to look at the
faces of the people I wasn't used to
giving talks then and there was a line
of people wanting to talk to me
afterwards it was insane
like people like this is why I came to
this conference to hear you like say
this was it just that they found the
vulnerability refreshing or what do you
think it was specifically that connected
I'm guessing I was probably the only one
who spoke that open at that conference
first but one but I think it was
something about just a reminder you know
like sometimes and a reminder and I
shared with them like look this was this
turn out to be over we all know we've
all been told love yourself right in
fact it's kind of annoying in cliche
right what I told them was like look I
was a bottom and I figured out a
practical way to do it for myself you
know because I needed it you know it was
the one thing that I felt something
inside me said this is gonna save you
and I just
with it I figured out in a very
practical you know I'm a Silicon Valley
guys that's looking for practical
methodical way that just that ended up
working for me so it's like I got the
secret it's not like hey love yourself
here's love yourself step one two three
four five bingo you'll love yourself you
know so I think I shared briefly quickly
than the steps and then they all wanted
to know more and like how to do them
uh-huh so that's what there was a line
afterwards and then when I was share of
her friends how to do it to be like all
these questions so which is why I
originally wrote the thing down to just
okay I'm just gonna give out copies to
people right right because he wasn't it
was it
you got a you got an email that you
forwarded to James and James is like
this you should write a blog post I'll
post it on my site and you were like
there's no way I'm doing no way man no
way I'd sent an email to a friend who's
gone through hard time just describing
briefly the app don't like the practical
yeah aspect of and it really helped him
and James like oh I'm gonna publish this
on my blog and this is before he had his
podcast yeah I'm like I was like no way
all my friends readers I'm terrified
like I but he's like he was really he's
responsible for this happening cuz he's
like look this you could write about
entrepreneurship you could write about
Fitness all these things plenty of
people can but this the most important
thing you're writing about are you sure
you know where that no one else is you
gotta put this out there he's usually
right about those things yeah and I
think he's been proven historically
correct in this case but his sweet spot
I mean he's basically created an entire
career about you know around having the
courage to share your you know your
failures and your your vulnerabilities
and he obviously identified something
special in your story and that kind of
dovetail you know right into the sweet
spot of the kind of things that he likes
to share about yeah and you know I still
didn't think I was gonna do it so I was
I tell you what you know I've been I've
been training myself to be a literary
fiction writer for like over a decade
was building startups right I wanted to
write literary novels you know like I
was just studying like crazy I was like
well let me write this down as a little
practical almost like a primer or
something and and I don't know we're
like over how we decide that if you
liked it I would self publish it at that
time you know at Kindle was out and like
you know they were like all these
success stories happening there and I
did it it took me a month and I sent it
to him and I didn't hear from a few
weeks and I was like oh thank god he
hates it I can move on like blah blah
blah because he's like I love it I'm
gonna write a blog post about you
publishing it but this day so that means
I had to publish it by that day and so
and so I I remember when I am a friend
of mine reached out to me she's like
come on do you remember her terrified
you were when you press submit on Kindle
like I think I was calling people's like
I don't wanna do this I don't want to do
this no one does best thing ever did
let's click that button yeah you know
and and it was a very short kind of
truncated version of what you know
ultimately you've recently published
right well he's kind of like a practical
manual it was more for primer because I
was scared I didn't know what to expect
if it's just like a little thing I was
gonna give out to people to friends
right who I knew needed it but it's like
you understand this when you find
something that works that makes you
better
you can't you kind of feel a
responsibility to share it you know you
really do like if that changed my life
uh-huh and so you when you expecially
when it's yours when you come up with it
you're like I got to share this cuz I'm
not you see the good impact it has on
you and then you see other people
struggling like wait I think I have a
solution here yeah you know at least try
it it worked for one human being it's on
the human mind the human heart you have
a human mind human heart try it out
right and it's a very basic thing but
when I put it out I held back a lot you
know cuz I was scared I wasn't expecting
it I don't want to share all my stories
or whatever but this exists actually not
because of me this exists because of
readers so I did something I didn't I
was expecting to sell a lot of copies so
I put my email address in the book I was
like hey if you got questions email me
guess what people emailed I have God
knows how many emails you know a lot of
a wonderful beautiful email saying how
it changed people's lives saying they're
literally saved their lives you know
like in the moment of reading the book
they decide to not kill themselves on
many of those and then just like how you
know changing their lives any of the
confidence self-esteem all this it all
arises from the same thing
and but there were questions and after
six seven years there's a whole you know
because I read all the emails or respond
to them is there's a pattern
you know this themes and I was like look
I held back and I realize I need to put
this book out if I'm gonna have it out I
need to have it on a real way I need to
I need those cautious resolve I know why
those questions are coming up is because
I held Mac so I got to stop holding back
yeah and so that's what I set out to do
and that's why I took seven years yeah
yeah yeah - what do you attribute the
virality of the original self-published
version
I mean you sold like half a million
copies right yeah it's crazy that didn't
start with James's blog or like how did
the word get out yeah start with James's
blog then people got on their own and
started tweeting it facebooking it it
was all over Facebook people were just
sharing a Facebook
Tim Ferriss tweeted about it that it got
him out of a funk so there were all
these people like trying to do it but
here's the interesting thing you know
I've built companies in Silicon Valley I
know
the online game very well like if you if
you get an app it's like if you're
looking at someone to invest in
someone's app right you look at the data
now you can game metrics you can buy
downloads you can game even book numbers
you can buy your own books and all that
right but with this what happened was it
it was just it came out as having like
this it shot up came down a little bit
and then just stayed for seven years
like that mmm just up there consistently
that is when you know you have something
special
trying to product us that whatever it is
you know it hit something you know what
it was it was I'm not a self up it's a
self up book written by a guy who's not
a self-help guy it's just a guy who
works on himself
who's lived a bit you know who shares
his personal journey exact and exactly
how he did it
and it's very easy to read easy to
digest it's very plain spoken on purpose
yeah yeah yeah well I want to I want to
work our way up to getting into the nuts
and bolts of the book but let's you know
take it back a little bit because I want
to better understand what got you to
this point
and and to kind of contextualize the
whole thing so you grow up in Queens
to make a single mom where rap Jamaica
Queens where I rap came from yeah from
there and and and my sense is that you
are always like your own person like not
not an easy person to control or Corral
yeah out of mind of your round yeah I
was always a pain the ass that way
uh-huh
school came easy it did it was boring I
never felt like I fit in anywhere you
know I never feel like I was a shy kid I
just read like crazy you know like I
read a lot books for my refuge as a
child we went through some really rough
stuff like really one point were
homeless you know how to abuse a dad
there's like you want to start listening
things we went to them and it was rough
and books with my refuge that's what I
escaped to and which everything is
amazing and now write books right but
yeah that was the childhood but I always
try I've almost done my own thing like
you when I went to college had a full
scholarship and after year I'd left it
and joined the army I know that's such a
strange choice like you know walk me
through that decision tree step one I'm
step two I'm in college for a year it's
a state school and you can get straight
A's without really going to classes just
partying bored out of my mind I want to
challenge third is step three I'm an
immigrant child I want to serve this
country you feel that you know people
often forget that about the immigrant
story just how much how grateful you
feel to this country you know for being
a part of it
and and I wanted to be challenged and I
wanted to just so all that put that
together and and just walking by
recruiters office one day decide to pop
in and they had a good sales pitch it
works man one by one Marines Navy all of
RMA airforce all of them that's what was
what was it that put the army over the
top yeah that's a great question right
that's a great question er because they
offered the most money for college
because I still need I wanted to get my
education it's very important to me but
I knew I didn't want to go to the state
school I wanted to go to a smaller
private school and to be able to afford
that also army would give me more money
because they also another day off one
morning they said okay I'll tell you
what you know they give you this test
called the ask web which is decides what
specialty you can choose I got ninety
eight and nine nine percent else I could
choose anything they like but if you
choose the one that people who fail take
it will give you more money which is
which is infantry your cannon fodder I
was like sweet but on top of that if you
take a harder one mountain infantry will
give you and more I was like sweet let's
just signed up for that the hardest
thing with the most financial upside but
you know it was great it's like the way
I look if you're gonna do something you
know do the do the did that y'all in
version will want to drop a truck
another part of the immigrant story you
know I presume that you know on some
level your parents immigrated here to
you know try to try to create a better
life or a different kind of life then
you know what was being experienced in
India so what's the phone call you know
back to mom like when you tell her you
you know it's actually a new person
think about it the life in in India they
had was like middle class upper middle
class but there's something about the
pull of America that draws people to it
because it is there's something special
about it
that so it wasn't like escaping from
poverty or anything like that you know
there is a there's a draw to this
country to to the freedom to be able to
do anything go anywhere I think that
that is also part of that immigrant
story although we didn't have that when
we came here you know it was pretty
quite the opposite in the beginning the
phone call to mom was a very interesting
one from college mom I'm thinking I join
the army pause okay
think carefully week later mom
I joined the army and and her reaction
silence silence that was it silence
uh-huh I mean I was at the agent she
couldn't do anything yeah that she knew
me
you had already established a pattern of
doing your own thing yeah and and she
had a healthy dose of like I can't
control this kid anyway she was like
this like you've gone forward with this
she was actually I remember she told me
disciplined yeah right yeah so boot camp
then right boot camp foot Benning
Georgia in middle this summer uh-huh
it was it was um I look back at that as
actually like a one of the defining
experiences of my life and I'm so glad I
gave myself that gift as an 18 year old
and I wasn't thinking of it that way
that back then cuz look you know if you
look any tribal society any primitive
Society Kotick or primitive you know
there's always a right of passage you go
through from going from boy to man you
know girl to woman there's something
about you challenged you tested then you
welcomed into the tribe now you're a man
now you like you've earned this right
we've missed that often in our society I
don't think college and partying is that
you know there's like something about
where you're challenged and you step up
and you step up you realize what you're
made of
mm-hmm boot camp did that for me and
then infantry boot camp did that for me
like every day you're challenged there's
no Pleasant day there's no like ah man
I'm just gonna sit here but I was still
the guy and and you know patrolling I'd
be like hey move because I'm standing
there looking at stars you know but a
sense of pride and ownership like yes I
did this hard thing this is mine
yes it was kind of cruising through
school there probably wasn't that same
you know sense of accomplishment yeah
there wasn't that at all at school yeah
and the military is good about that they
do give you that you know they do
challenge you and and they do make you
feel like you earn what you get uh-huh
yeah they're very good about that and
were you deployed no I I was in during
Desert Shield as a storm by the time
they said hey V may deploy you I was
light infantry mountain infantry the
thing was over because it was an air war
uh-huh
so you're just hanging out in Georgia
Georgia at Fort Drum yeah just I am
funny enough I ran into someone who's in
10th mod in the flight here and randomly
I never meet people we were talking
she's like yeah I was deployed all the
time I was like yeah well you actually
worked I didn't see that
you know kudos to you so how
long were you in the military then total
up think a little over three years had
it sounded reserves cuz I went to school
have a chance to go to you a private
school upstate New York so I went there
so he took that that's sweet army money
put it to work it wasn't dad's turned
out to be none much haha it was it was
all it was all marketing fluff
oh yeah tonight be a little there's all
these stipulations you know when you're
18 year old signing a contract you do
not look at the fine print you just said
they just said this much money you said
okay sweet it's painted when the rubber
meets the road is like there's loads of
fine for it but I'm still you know
that's fine so you go back to school
what's the plan the plan is to it wasn't
a plan I was studying economics at the
time end up studying economics and
biology and I thought I was gonna go to
med school and be a emergency pediatric
person I was working hospitals and level
one trauma centers to get that
experience you know for med school
what was the allure of medicine do
something useful like it was like I
could go anywhere in the world and be
useful
I could land in a random village in
Timbuktu where you know and I could be
useful that's what it was yeah and so
how come that didn't happen I took a
break I backpacked around for a while my
dad died I went to India to cos ashes
there we weren't close at all so we were
estranged but I was with him when he
died and I was leaving the hospital when
he died and it was being in the hospital
watching experience kind of shook me up
I couldn't be and I had to get away from
hospitals for a little while and when I
came back I end up actually wandering
for the back way for about eight months
through India and your Nepal and Europe
with like three thousand dollars to my
name nothing more like no credit cards
nothing and living I think in Europe on
five dollars a day that was my budget
three dollars a day and when I came back
I knew I wanted to write what I'd
experienced I want to I knew I had
stories to tell so I started writing and
I was looking at Medical School and then
Silicon Valley was how
thing and my brother he he called me
said hey get the New York Times this
weekend
I said why he said just got the New York
Times said ok and so I'm reading the New
York Times and figure out why and the
Sunday magazine there's a two-page write
up with my little brother mmm you know
on this of this company has started I
was out for Asia list
no no Angeles is more massive that was
way back in the day like you know the
first up in Rio so we're early dot-com
boom early dot-com boom and a two-page
write-up I mean in fact Amazon reviews
on all this stuff copied buddy built
they didn't have that like that's you
know and all this ratings that exist in
the web exists because of what he built
and I called him up and he's like look
what are you doing watching people die
every day
he said come out here we're building the
future I was like man you know I was
kind of warned of what some people dial
earth and and I just finished a first
draft of terrible terrible draft of a
novel right you went like you went up
Upstate tops in upstate New York and
hold up to try to write a novel right
yeah yeah and wrote it and it was
atrocious absolute Roshan you know six
months you know but sometimes you got to
do the atrocious to understand that
looked as a path to not atrocious of
course this this book here doesn't exist
without doing the atrocious writing Oh
God through the decades I've done those
10,000 hours yeah and when he said that
I thought about it and I was at the gym
that Gold's Gym most working this guy
and I was talking to him I was like man
I want to go out there but I'm scared
I'm like you know there's what if he's
like look come on I have one piece of I
said what he said leap and then that
will appear and I don't know what it was
but literally that shifted for me right
there mmm-hmm so I got rid of everything
bought a one-way ticket and just moved
out and leap and the net will appear
yeah and it's something I've learned
that's how it works it does it
absolutely I mean that's I've had many
experiences with that very thing and
what I've also noticed is when I try to
sidestep that by having my foot in
both camps at the same time trying to do
the safe and secure thing like well I
can't quite leave this thing yet so I'm
gonna develop this on the side and when
it matures then I'll take the leap when
it's safe never works out yeah I mean
maybe it does for other people there's a
there's a rational argument for that but
there is something I think transcendent
and magical when you have the faith and
the courage to completely let go of
what's not serving you and and take that
step into the unknown and in my
experience when you do that full of
heart well intentioned and prepared to
work your ass off that inevitably
something happens to catch that fall and
create a soft landing that is in us well
I think it's one of the fundamental
truths of life it really is but there's
no way to learn it you have to
experience it you know it's scary yeah
scary each time you do it yeah because
it's a different it's a different cliff
were jumping off different scenery but
you got little bro out there killing it
and we should say your brother is
involved right yes he's kind of become
like a guru in his own right it's good
an amazing thing right what's going on I
don't know I don't know man maybe it's
in the blood who knows but you know he
was doing his own thing I went there do
my own thing and so I end up like
working there and building startups and
kind of fell in love with it like the
ability to create these companies and no
one knowing what they're doing we're
just making it up at the point right
figure it out and just throwing it
online and seeing if it works if not
you're iterating and there was a there
was a energy that I hadn't experienced
before there was an excitement and
energy of building the future well it
was this crazy moment where ideas could
get funded seemingly overnight and
turned into these realities we just had
the experience that with the
cryptocurrency boom saying but
cryptocurrency was way more scammy you
know yeah but yeah it really was and
people coming from all over the world
from there just to like you know go west
it was it was literally go west young
man all over it right and it was a very
special moment in time and that's where
I trained but I look at that as my MBA
right
you know you just get thrown in a little
cup we have to okay now be we've gone
public we're gonna figure how to
monetize our oh come on figure it out
okay I'll figure out a monetize this
public company on the web you know kids
just no one knew did you have a sense
that that you're kind of
multidisciplinary approach to life
served you in that regard like as
somebody who had a you know a kind of
variety of interests and and you know
kind of a jack of all trades master of
none approach came in handy for that
kind of thing you know it's interesting
I asked that because I used to beat
myself up when I was younger for having
too many interests which is why I
struggled with the whole medical school
thing because as much as I wanted to be
a doctor I knew would have to give
everything else up I'd love to travel I
love to take all this time to read and
write do do these other things right and
startups to be able to build a company
from scratch and go take it somewhere
you basically have to do everything and
it turned out to be what I thought was
my greatest weakness turned out to be
you take you what is you think is your
weakness you just put a different
environment it's your greatest strength
mm-hmm so yeah it was a perfect faith
and that was part of the reason why I
made that choice because I was
flourishing in that we're people prior
to that throughout your life telling you
you need to focus yes oh my god you
could be so great just pick a lane yeah
yeah that makes you think about how many
people are out there being fed you know
some version of that story who you know
don't find that situation where suddenly
the round peg fits into the round hole
you know that's probably more common
than not yeah I would say so I think
that's the best thing is like switch
your environment if that environment is
not the fit but it's hard yeah it's hard
to do so you build and you build a bunch
of startups multiple companies over the
years rocking and rolling off and on
yeah I mean it's it had to be pretty
exciting boys money emotions good I mean
most never go anywhere that's a very
little secret to startups right huh like
nine
something percent fail that's what
really blurred alike screenwriters in
Hollywood your projects you know there's
so many projects that you think are
gonna go people toil on them for years
and then they just end up in a drawer
somewhere yeah but Lisa in Hollywood
they get paid for doing those like uncle
B we're gonna start up four years making
practically nothing and it goes nowhere
uh-huh no and so some went places
somewhere nowhere but it was it was a
good gig yeah no complaints I enjoyed it
and I enjoyed working with some of the
smartest people on the planet you meet
people who are stupidly scarily smart
you know but everyone's smart in their
own way and then to be surround with
people are smart in this in a way that
I'm not and to be able to work with them
and lead them and and learn from them
was was beautiful what are some of the
biggest lessons that you learned during
that tenure about life and business you
know what's interesting the lessons I
learned were stuff I knew and like like
for example I developed a reputation for
being able to build really great teams
just be able to get really great people
to come on board for my crazy ideas for
be paying them nothing when they were
getting massive offers like how you know
what I would basically I just did what I
learned in the military you know someone
used the word men because I was in the
infantry it was all men or boys or
whatever and you take care of men if
you're leading you take care of them you
eat last you know they you you show up
first
you leave last you lead by example like
when you go to Fort Benning I remember
being in that bus being taken from
Atlanta Airport to Fort Benning and
there's a statue they're very famous
statue of the offered infantrymen in
World War two and he's got his rifle and
he's got his hand up like this and he's
charging forward and says follow me
that's basically leadership in a
nutshell follow me and so that's how I
built stuff like I was the hardest
worker I was a lowest paid guy I led
like all the credit always went to the
team never took any credit you know cuz
I don't care if we win I'll do just fine
I'd rather have the rewards to the
credit
and and but that came from any an 18
year old you know I didn't learn
anything like that doing it I learned it
it's very interesting yeah that is
interesting so there's a good chance
that you know short of some experiences
that you that you have that we're
working our way towards this could have
just gone on ad infinitum iterating on
on you know startups going from startup
to startup and then writing novels on
the side and collected rejection letters
did you keep the writing up precisely
throughout all of this yeah that's what
I did in every time obsessively studying
the greats like a certain Hemingway
books I read on are 20 30 40 times
underlining see how he did what he did I
was obsessed uh-huh but never the
thought that that this that that would
become your vocation this was something
you did purely for the love for the love
and and people like what are you doing
missing your time your decadent was
getting rejection letters like what are
you doing right but it was like I knew I
I wanted to put books out there I just
didn't know if it was gonna happen in
fact by the time I wrote the original
love yourself I'd given up on writing
for a couple years I hadn't written for
a couple of years but man that training
that I thought have been useless you
know I came out and it's been amazing
yeah so talk to me about the
precipitating event that catalyzed this
whole this whole thing like well ears
thing like like all great you know
personal evolutions begin with some you
know act of destruction and you know it
lends itself to the belief that you know
these amazing epiphanies about the human
condition grow they emanate out of the
ashes of you know just you know various
forms of disaster well you know to be if
those opportunities exist they're there
they're there for the taking for anybody
you can read your book and and you know
get a sense of you know what led you to
this point that set you want a new
trajectory but the opportunity exists
for anybody to take advantage of these
tools for personal growth and evolution
shy of having
you know meet your maker so to speak but
unfortunately pain is the ultimate
motivator it does get your attention
I'll tell you that you know it's like
I've thought about this and it's like to
be a phoenix you got to burn yeah it's
like the whole process of rebirth it's
not it's not easy it's not painless
mm-hmm
you know like so said the precipitating
event or what led to love inciting
incident so what does he call in
chemistry yeah you know when the
reaction happens I was I'd built a
company I'd self-funded it for how this
was gonna be my fu money company right
and I was doing very well I was taking
out I was actually taking away real
business from Google Yahoo and a
vertical no one ever done before I was
pulling it off but the great team got
the deals and no one could get it was
like a I was obsessed right and and I
was built three and a half years and
then I ran out of money you know
building a tech company three enough
years you run out himself fun to have
fun yeah all right pretty much everyone
for a couple yeah and I took investment
and it was doing well and the whole
thing blew up and I lost everything you
know I was lost my company but along
with it I lost my my sense of self-worth
if to put it mildly cuz my company was
my complete identity you know what I was
doing was my identity I I was depressed
beyond belief I had no money I was
living off credit cards I remember
having to make some payroll on the side
to some of my employees of credit cards
of like look man you bought him a crazy
dream I can't have your wife and kids
because you know Wow and it was a it was
it rough to be an understatement there
were times where I was like look I
remember looking at the Bay Bridge from
my window and really like I was so
exhausted I was burnt out I was like I
was like really sick burnt out you know
whatever they call it you know fatigued
all the works like I went to some doctor
who worked with me later on it and I
didn't have the strength to walk over
the bay bridge and throw myself off
otherwise I would have you know I was
literally like that and I think it was
the next night or the night after that I
remember getting up and I was like
I was miserable I was like I can't do
this I gotta get out of this I mean
again I get out of this a guy trying
that's it I can't be in this space and I
walked over to my desk and I have a
journal that I write in and in there and
I still don't know where it came from i
sat down and I wrote a vow to myself now
I do believe in the power of personal
commitment like if I make a commitment
to myself I'm gonna keep it that's
something I've had for a while something
I've trained myself for a while but a
vow I've never written a vow to myself
that I don't know where that word came
from and then it was a vow to love
myself it came in the moment I am NOT a
guy who is thinking about hey you know
what I need we go what I really need I
think I need to love myself that never
occurred to me once but yet in that
moment that's what came out where did it
come from where is that what's that deep
stillness that you know runs the whole
show yeah you know well you have this
you know crushing incident your ego is
is crashing down you've been humbled
you've been stripped away from all of
the externalities that you were living
for and it's like a deconstruction of
your character all the way to your very
core right like there's few things more
painful in life and to be confronted
with that presents you with a choice
like destruction or rebirth the bridge
or in your case finding a way to love
yourself and they're both very timely I
mean in fact that bridge is more
tempting than they'll ever see I'll be
honest because the bridge is easy love
yourself what does that even mean yeah I
remember sitting back kind of looking at
myself like looking at this like what
have I just done but I've written a vow
right to myself like there was something
there like that doesn't just happen and
so I was like all right now what I'll
have to figure this out I'm have to do
this now even though I've read a book
about it I didn't go read books on it
you know anything I've come across and
that genre had been all like platitudes
but nothing I'm a big believer and like
if if someone's unfired
don't lecture to them about kanae chura
combustion throw water on them
right I didn't practical solution
solutions show me how to mind how to fix
my mind you know this misery this pain
this angst I'm man get me out of it and
so I was like well it's my mind so who's
gonna work on it for me I am I have no
choice I made this vow so I and now I
have a direction of this this love this
l.o.v.e word which I wasn't even sure
what it meant and so I started to try to
do it and I didn't know what I tried
like I was like a crazy mad scientist in
my apartment just trying things I was
like should I write it down this many
times a day this - should I like just
feel excited what should I like it's
Charlie's things and at one point I
stumbled a little I was tired I was like
you know what I'm just gonna stop saying
it to myself because that's one thing I
can do and so start repeating it to
myself and he's interesting that
happened after a couple of days I had
nothing else to do and the company was
god I had no money like I wasn't like
any shape to go get a job very alright
time and you know I had a credit limit
on my credit cards and something said to
shift after I think about two or three
days and you know it's my mind I'm
keeping again aside notice I start to
feel a little better
and all I've been doing was just running
there's just looping this phrase yeah
telling yourself time and time again I
love myself myself that's simple and I
was like okay this it could be basically
because by doing this one loop I'm
actually keeping all the other loops
from running you know with the
self-destructive loops or the negative
loops but could be maybe I'm going
somewhere deeper and after three four
days I remember I was like well let me
try to feel it and I started making
myself feel it you know and it feels
really fake in the beginning what what
is the process of going from head to
heart with that like the the distinction
between repeating this mantra time and
time again and attempting to feel it
well this is what I came up with was I
somehow connected the sense of light to
the feeling of love I don't remember I
think it might have been because of the
moonlight was coming in one night
through the window as I was doing this
and I was feeling the light coming from
the like a big moon and big you know
window
and in the bay and yeah that's what it
was I forgot it right and and so I
remember trying to feel like light
coming in and I would take a deep breath
but the light coming and I would imagine
this is not just a life in the moon it's
like all day it's like galaxy's tipping
over and just a light pouring from them
into my head just coming in and the
light coming in through my body as I
breathe in and I'm feeling and I'm
feeling the love coming and then I just
breathe out whatever gunk needs to go
mm-hmm and I started doing that and that
shifted things like that that was like
okay there's something here and what was
that shift like what what was the
physical manifestation of that you
notice you notice like a heaviness that
goes away yeah you know and in fact when
I was just describing I was kind of sort
of doing it and I felt like my my chest
feel lighter it's there's a you're
absolutely right there is a physical
component to it that I've sort of
forgotten cuz now I just do this a lot
of this an autopilot but that was one of
the things and then I started doing a
meditation with it so I was just
practicing trying things cuz I like I
said I had a vow and nothing else to do
and something was working and so i if it
didn't shift things I threw it away
and so by the end I basically taken this
basic loop and built like a practice
around it off a meditation of like a
seven meditation of looking in the
mirror doing it to myself which is more
of a physical anchoring myself to my
physical self and then walk into this
mental loop and I started to shift
everything inside right I wasn't lost at
that take less than weeks a couple of
weeks yeah you know keep in mind it was
a trial error there's a lot of trial and
error going on and a lot of disbelief I
did it because I had nothing else is
doing because I made a foul and I was
desperate because there was the Bay
Bridge that was my other choice right
desperation feels willingness though
yeah what I think is really interesting
about this is that the typical reaction
to experiencing something devastating
would be to seek out a therapist go to
the doctor or perhaps even you know go
to an ashram
or seek out a guru or start reading a
bunch of books like to to seek
externally for answers but in your case
you kind of did the opposite like you
just went in deeper and deeper and
deeper and experimented with your own
intuition and instincts the tools that
came out of this are not I mean there
are other people that do you know
variations of the things that you're
talking about so it's not like you
invented something that didn't already
exist few you but you had to discover it
within your own personal experience
rather than sit at the foot of a guru
and have that person tell you to do that
yeah I remember why I didn't seek
externally as part of it is I'm kind of
I'm almost trying to figure things out I
was been that kid who's trying to figure
out the nature of reality since as far
as I can remember and but you're right
it was instinct but it was also like I
didn't think I could go to anyone with
the level of desperation I felt like I'd
done therapy in college was a one of the
best things I ever did to to you know go
some childhood stuff but I'd done it
right I'm try remember this is a great
point I'm trying to member why I just
went in I think because of that vow and
I was like I made a vow to myself I
gotta keep it to myself
and was there a fear of letting anyone
else know what you were just crazy talk
yes yeah but no I mean just calling your
friend and saying listen I'm thinking
about jumping off the bridge like I'm in
a I'm in a bad state like I need help or
were you just were you I sing and like
determined to figure it out on your own
the lazar hose to silver help the liar
because that can also be that can lead
people to do the greater depths of that
can lead them to their bridge yeah that
was I wouldn't recommend it you know
been down that path it's there's many
paths of transformation some are easier
than others I would recommend easier
path so I had yesterday I had this guy
Shane parish in here Tina's Farnam
Street yeah and
and there's an interesting juxtaposition
between the things that we talked about
and what he talks about in his writing
and his and in his book and-and-and what
you talked about in that Shane is a guy
who has a computer scientist mind and
realized that nobody had really
canonized how to make good decisions and
so he sought he sought he went out into
the world and canvassed the best
information possible and tried to create
like a latticework and encyclopedic
lattice work of how to make good
decisions what you're saying you know
what I mean like in a very kind of
rational logical way saying we need we
need a better guide on how we're making
decisions that impact our lives so we
can lead better lives and create better
businesses etc and his so his focus was
was was very much a looking outward what
are the what are the greatest minds of
all time what have they had to say about
this let me take the best of that and
figure out a way to synthesize it in a
way that can that can help me help me
figure out like a program for lack of a
better word to make better decisions in
your case there's there's there's an
analogy here and kind of a converse
relationship in that you looked inward
and rather rather than than going
outward and saying what are the greatest
most enlightened minds have to say about
how I can get myself out of this hole
you just went inward and trusted your
instinct you know it was it was very
much an emotional spiritual journey of
trying to deepen your connection with
self and and and not be influenced by
the outside world man you should have
been around then put it beautifully know
what I was doing right and and in that
original version of the book and now you
know full more fully fleshed out and
significantly yes actually in love
yourself like your life depends on it
you you kind of walk people through like
here's what I did and here's how you can
do it too and there's a variety of
practices that begin with
being this mantra of I love myself
you've got a breath work practice ten
breaths this meditation practice where
in your case it's seven minutes you find
a song that you know basically allows
you to anchor yourself and that's a
daily thing this mirror practice which I
want to talk about and they're all like
very short easy things to do when
undertaking consistently can really
shift those neural pathways and and and
alter you know how you how you how you
feel physically and how you feel
emotionally yeah because that comes from
just like I want to be efficient which
is called basic I'm lazy you know at
least amount of work for the greatest
greatest impact and and I don't want to
spend the rest of my life walking around
doing like a crazy man
you know just speaking to myself I love
myself right so like I was just trying
out what is what causes the greatest
shift that I can do and just start doing
those regularly mm-hmm so these were
some of the things that ten breaths one
is really it's simple man it's so simple
but I've been through it it's so
remember the prior what I told you about
it's so we're breathing every day and by
the way want to or not until they're not
so ten breaths throughout the day like
actually I was doing on the on the uber
ride here I'll actually just pause from
everything like if I can't I'll close my
eyes and I'll take a deep the ten deep
and purposeful breaths exact intentional
breaths this is but these ten breaths
this is what I'm doing this is one be
and with the in-breath same thing the
light from galaxies coming in above the
light but the light comes a feeling of
love you know we're wired for light and
are you saying I love myself as you're
doing that sometimes sometimes no
sometimes just feeling the love because
I have anchored the feeling of light to
love right and you just if you do it
enough times it just becomes natural and
I feel the love come in and just go in
and I just feel my heart on my chest
just to open and get lighten and then I
just breathe out and then what happens
is usually about the sixth or seventh I
notice automatically but I'm breathing
I'm breathing out thank you so breathing
love
breathe out thank you ten breaths just
throughout the day pause and do that it
settles you better than anything it's a
very simple thing yeah
added these throughout the basic what
I've done in the book I've showed all
the different things I do pick and
choose what works for you but this has
also the core practice but that's that
one anyone can do anywhere you're doing
that all you can do in the shower you
have no excuse not to bring what's funny
is that is that they're so simple right
and and it's easy to to dismiss them as
hokey right like you think this is like
Stuart Smalley looking in the mirror on
sorry you're worth it and you have value
you know and it's just like come on man
are you serious but I know that the that
these techniques are effective I can't
say that I've practiced this specific
regimen but I do have a very good friend
I'm part of a like a men's group I get
together with with a group of guys once
a week and we with a therapist and we
talk about things that are going on in
our life and there's one friend who was
part of this and he has been doing this
very I don't think he's read your book
but he has been he has been practicing
the I love I love myself mantra and he's
been doing the mirror work basically for
the last I think like maybe four or five
weeks spending time in front of the
mirror like just staring into his eyes
and saying I love my he's read the book
myself and and he has been sharing that
it has been completely transformative
and this is somebody who is already very
much you know a spiritually advanced
individual like this guy's not new to
you know techniques like this he's
already like you know a very evolved
human being and he has been telling us
that like this is really notch things up
to a whole nother level for him and in
the way he's experiencing the world
that's awesome
yeah you know it's you know an art you
know so you know what is a simplicity is
ultimate sophistication if you create
you got to distill down to the simplest
simplest thing that's where it works
that's what the truth is it's easy to
create complicated practices and you
know I could have put in all sorts of
incense bowls and this and that it would
be very great for
but people like that though they're like
take me yeah I get that I love myself
but like take me behind the velvet rope
like what's the VIP version of this it's
the same thing like you know look I've
been and I've been in 12-step forever
and you're like really it's the same
steps I haven't updated this thing you
know it's like secret well you know I
have to like do an inventory again come
on like give me the give me the advanced
program the ap version well it did
something in the book that in the new
version that does help does kind of go
there which is I took an experience of
when I felt this is this is after I've
been doing the practice and I kind of
got Lee I got very lazy and let life get
in the way and I fell apart yeah you
know it turns out this is the whole
third part of the book yeah it turns out
you don't just fall apart once in life
yeah you know yeah and and what I did
was I started doing the practice again
from scratch because I've been doing it
for a long time I'd gotten lazy you know
and I'm the guy who wrote the damn book
right and so what I did was I wrote down
exactly what I went through also the
inside and shared that in here so one
can actually see it okay it's not just
like here do this this work and do that
but actually see me doing it and see the
inside effects so it's the nuances
matter in these things see the nuances
that are happening see the shifts that
are happening see what I'm doing right
see what I'm doing wrong and let me
point it out to you which is actually
again I wanted to cut that part out so
badly because it's so honest so
vulnerable and it's thanks to Gideon he
was like no no no this is a reason why I
know that's a [ __ ] yeah I mean that's a
cool thing because it reinforces our
shared humanity like we are fallible
human beings this is a practice this
isn't something you do and go oh it's
all good and I did that and now I'm
moving on to this other part of my life
like this is this is a recursive thing
it compounds over time but if you take
your foot off the gas you're gonna reset
and you're ultimately you know gonna
regress and the way I like to think
about I mean I think it's profound and I
think that that third part really
anchors that whole idea in it you know
in a really grounded and beautiful way
you know I have my own version of of
that story you know it was it was a it
was impressed upon me when I was in
rehab like look you know every moment
every decision that you make every
thought you entertain every every person
that you encounter these things are
either moving you you know back towards
a drink or moving you further away from
a drink you're either growing or you're
regressing
there is no stasis as human beings we
want to believe that we can arrive at a
static state and and that's a great
delusion that I think leads most of us
astray and when I was finishing finding
ultra in late 2011 this memoir about
addiction and recovery and this you know
journey towards greater self
actualization I I I relapse like thirty
thirteen years sober and I and I
relapsed and this you know I'm turning
in the manuscript like this books almost
done and it was one of the most shameful
embarrassing things I could ever
possibly imagine like how could I
actually pick up a drink after 13 years
when I'm about to put up put out this
book that talks about this journey
towards sobriety as one very significant
component of it and it's the very same
thing which is that I you know got to a
place where I was on cruise control
and thought that I had it handled I
never questioned whether or not I was an
alcoholic but I took my foot off the gas
and deprioritized my engagement with
12-step in that community and ultimately
you know after you know a year of that
it was inevitable that what happened
happened and luckily I found my way back
immediately and I've shared about this
publicly many times but and and and now
I look at it as a gift because it
rebooted my my engagement with that with
that aspect of who I am and really
reinforced this idea that it is a
practice and that this is not something
you're gonna ultimately transcend like
you this is oh I woke up again today
okay I gotta go do that thing again
you know yeah it's a it is a practice
and like I used the word coasting and
that's one of the reasons why I know
like look here's the dangers of coasting
and hairs and but really that third part
you know every time by getting while
Harper won he's the reason why that's
still there I was too terrified but I'm
glad I kept that because that's been
very impactful to people yeah I think
the vulnerability in it is is powerful
so why don't we explain what it is what
it is that that that kind of catalyzed
that well it was a really traumatic
breakup so when I loved dearly still
love you know and and wasn't my choice
and you know I just kind of I'd been
going through stuff at the time anyway
and that was like the incident that just
kind of made me come apart at the wheels
and and but the interesting thing was
I'm like part of it there was I
should've is that shame I was like look
I'm the guy who wrote the book on how
not to how to be how to fix this stuff
right you've graduated I have graduated
up I got a date I got a corporate job
you know like and and that was actually
so I actually kind of struggled and I
fought it almost like I was like well
maybe it won't work this time because
I've fallen off this wagon and but it's
like in the end of as I go what you know
that works you got to go back to what
you know that works and I started doing
it almost grudgingly almost like [ __ ]
cause you can cuz you and you know what
started to work I started to work I
started to work and so I would show how
I did the process kind of like ass
backwards and I say like look this is
the actual process is taking me this
long because I'm I'm fighting it and but
look even as I'm fighting it would look
at what's happening inside look at the
effect every single word every single
word in this book is true it has
happened it's what I felt it's what I
experienced yeah but man that was
interesting feeling the internal shame I
remember sitting at the airport getting
ready for flight to San Francisco just
reading David gagas book has come I had
come out you know and I was reading it
and I was like you know when you read
someone like David guys I feel like damn
that guy's impressive you know I didn't
feel like me I just felt a part of gay
and like a mirror for our own
right well I think I think what what is
profound about it is that is that you
know destruction it's like what you said
like you know if you want to be a
Phoenix you got to burn liked the
opportunity finds its moment in
destruction right and it's it's this
grand opportunity to deepen your
surrender to something more powerful
than yourself right it's a it's a it's
you're being asked to you know prostrate
yourself a little bit lower to you know
to really give over your ego even more
to humble yourself and and to and to you
know let go like you're being confronted
with your character defects in a really
profound way right so then you have to
forgive yourself again and you have to
do it even more profoundly than you had
to prior
yeah it's actually you know I'm learning
like life you know it's like a building
a start-up excuse the analogy buddy no
company just a rocket ship straight up
to the right it's like it's it's loops
you know and but there is something to
be said about consistency in what you
would really matters like fitness right
if you're not consistent in your
practice it'll show your body will show
the same of the mind and the mind is
actually more plastic more malleable
than anything else yet it's the one that
we work on the least we really do right
right we really overlook it
and so that's starting to change but
it's starting to change but there's a
lot of stuff out there that's I don't
know as a physic Tavor not there's a lot
of stuff out there in the end it's got
to be something what is the best workout
what is the best nutrition plan it's the
one you can do consistently you know
that's that's what you got to go for
what it's consistently again that gives
you results let's go back to forgiveness
for a minute I think that's an important
piece and all of this so how do you
think about and practice that well
forgiveness there's two forms right
forgiving others are forgiving yourself
the novel that I wrote rebirth that's
about forgiveness but that's about
forgiving my father after he died the
whole journey while
I walked a pale pilgrimage in Spain and
the result of that pilgrimage was I
learned how to forgive him right like
550 miles since yeah Camino de Santiago
and you know what it was
in the end it was just learned realizing
his humanity he was a human being
man you can't hold humans to two
criteria of God's you know what we seem
to do that with a you know and this
really his humanity that's when you
realize how much humanity is very easy
to forgive but in order to do that you
have to you have to transcend your child
your childhood lens on your parent yeah
and and and shift that perspective to
see it through the eyes of the parents
or to see the eyes if a human being
looking another human being you can
never completely remove that right the
parent but if you can just do human
being to another human being that right
away chef said and we'll see their
struggles you know they're even faulty
decision making whatever but their
struggles and that when you understand
that if forgiveness actually comes
naturally she can't help it you can't
understand you know you don't you don't
have to accept it you don't have to say
yes I agree I'm glad you you were that
way you know I'm glad you did XYZ but
you can because forgiveness ultimately
is freeing yourself yeah I think we look
at it as a two-way street like I'll
forgive you when you ask me for
forgiveness or you admit what you did
and how you wronged me but ultimately
the person who's carrying the resentment
or the anger or that pain is the one who
is suffering the one who is the object
of being not forgiven is often even
unaware is that's a great iron so it's a
self-inflicted harm I was at an event a
thing last night it's another like
little group thing that I do that was
created by this organization called the
Nantucket project and they created these
neighborhood they're they're called
neighborhood projects where little you
know small groups of people get together
and they watch a short film that the
Nantucket project produces and then
there's a discussion ensues kind of like
to create you know you know greater
community in our neighborhood
and the movie that that we watched last
night in this group setting was a short
documentary about the genocide in Rwanda
and how the President of Rwanda was
faced with this prospect of how to
repair his country in the aftermath of
this horrible tragedy and the story is
told from his perspective and also
through the perspective of a perpetrator
of the genocide somebody who killed a
lot of people and a woman who whose
family have been killed and ultimately
it's a story about how these two people
forgive each other
Wow and it's incredibly inspiring and it
left me thinking about the incredible
exponential power of forgiveness I think
there's something beautifully
transcendent and unique about
forgiveness in that it holds this
potential energy capacity to to be so
incredibly transformative maybe it's
because it's rare I don't know what it
is about it uniquely but but to see that
it's impossible not to be moved and it
leaves you thinking about the people in
our own lives that that we refuse to
forgive or the resentments that we hold
on to about how we've been wronged in
the pain that that creates and the
impediments to moving forward that that
constructs in our lives and also about
the people that we've harmed and
thinking more deeply about people who
might be out in the world carrying that
kind of pain over things that we might
have done yeah and the salt and then and
then forgiving ourselves right to repeat
and loop the mantra I love myself I
think self forgiveness is a subset of
that yeah that's actually the other part
of forgiveness right so forgiveness what
I found you know for me it's um what
I've learned is start with the self
first you work in the self the rest
actually gets easier that's just
naturally starts to work and same thing
with here was like in this book you
never practice that I do in forgiving
myself and it actually works beautifully
and it's a very practical practice you
know like everything is practical you
can do it
and you will notice the shift and what I
learned was I didn't have that in the
original version what I've learned is if
you're gonna make of commitment to love
yourself you can do this practice you
know leave the path you leave the shot
you can't leave them past me I believe
the shackles of the past behind and what
you do is you forgive yourself and then
you start to love yourself mm-hmm that's
call most like the step by step right
and mix it makes a huge difference and
again it's not platitudes actually how I
do it it's like you know I mean if very
quickly it's like I I don't know why I
come up with these crazy things I had a
I had a girlfriend at the time and she
was really holding on to some stuff
against herself and I was like look I
think I know what to do come with me so
we drove down to Pescadero and by the
beautiful like just open land a cliff of
looking with the oceans by the
lighthouse
it's an incredible beach oh it's very
wild one of my favorite places of
planning you can watch whales go by it
since it's amazing right
rugged melt in California and we got
there and I gave her a piece of paper
and a pen I said look write down
everything you holding is yourself start
with I forgive myself for then I forgive
myself for just keep on doing keep on
doing until you're spent and she said
okay she said but then you have to do
this to [ __ ] all right
okay I wasn't planning on it and because
what it was for was then she's like you
haven't forgiven yourself for not going
to medical school you beat yourself up
for it you need to redo this for that I
was like okay so I sat down I wrote all
the ways I forgave myself for not going
to medical school and then we both read
ours out loud away from each other so
it's a property cos anything out loud
until you just really feel the weight of
what you've been carrying you have to
feel the weight there's a weight all
right it's a physical thing and you read
out a lot and if not you've you you feel
the way you like I'm done carrying this
I let it go and then just ball to the
paper walked out to the ocean okay and
then just threw it far as I could mm-hmm
and you know what it worked I literally
ever since that that whole thing about
not going to medical school disappeared
and her thing disappeared and I've done
this other times in my life for other
things are just like generally hey I
forgive myself are we
over the last three months being human
at all
and you know like when when I fell apart
with the break-up I had I did this
exercise to forgive myself for knowing
better you know for for falling apart
and for you know not being better and it
works it's really it's a simple things
and I think part of the reason why it
works and I say like look you'd have to
bail by an ocean you can set on fire you
can throw it on the toilet doesn't
matter the intention because you realize
the weight of what you're carrying is
that I let this go right I choose to let
this go and it's that act of deciding
that's something inside chef's it's very
similar to step forward step five and
twelve step do you know that no oh my
god it's yeah I mean basically step four
involves doing this inventory of your
life and your behavior sexual inventory
a resentment inventory it's a very
robust document that you work on over
time to kind of perjure to get clarity
on where your character defects come up
and how you participate in these crises
that you form stories around and and
ultimately to to then give it over to
let it go to surrender and you know in
in the case of 12-step it's like letting
the higher power take it and take it for
you and letting it go and there is there
it is it is a it is a transformative
experience like I the first time that I
did it I was in rehab in Oregon and I
went I finished my inventory and I drove
to the the beach another rugged you know
Pacific sat on the side of a beach by
myself and did a private ceremony and I
and then I and then I burned it you know
it was a similar to you know the kind of
experience and and it was incredible how
different I felt even after that but
here's the thing we already kind of
touched on it a minute ago
but that doesn't mean you're done no you
go back you gotta go back in and it's
like okay you went through that all
right time to start again but then it's
like not just forgiving yourself it's
like who you're gonna be now
right that's where that what I realized
for the next step is you make a
commitment to yourself to you know for
me it was loving myself and that's right
this whole book is about you then you
make that commitment and then how do you
keep that commitment day by day by day
so it becomes a way of being uh-huh and
the effects just happen in your life my
favorite of all of these tools is is
this other recursive phrase which is if
I love myself what would I do or some
version of that right yeah if I love my
what would be the right action here if I
actually love myself yeah it's a cushion
that came up with when I realized I was
making poor choices and and you know
like if you most of the time in our and
I realized in our head we're basically
answering questions that's what we're
doing with asking asking courses are and
so it was like why don't just create a
question that I asked myself whenever
I'm making it have to make choices just
to make it a habit and and the Bute the
best part was the if if I loved myself
because then it doesn't have to be I
have to be loving myself in the moment
if I love myself of what I do because
then you know the answer then it becomes
a conscious decision I can still choose
to make the the choice I you know I
shouldn't make right the choice had the
poor choice whatever you want to call
that but at least I'm doing a
consciously you start living more
consciously that way and sooner or later
you get tired of you know making the
poor choice consciously you stop making
a better choice I was practicing it
yesterday
oh yeah it's incredibly practical mm-hmm
and it really it makes you confront
yourself like I was just I was in the
grocery store and I'm walking down the
aisles and I'm like what am I gonna eat
it's like I'm I wanna I want to get this
thing and I'm like if I love myself is
that the choice that I have if I love
myself what would I actually choose and
of course you're gonna you're gonna say
well I would choose the healthy thing
the thing that's gonna make my body
healthier and stronger right and if you
have that in your conscious awareness as
you're navigating these seemingly like
small little decisions that you have to
make throughout the day there is a there
is a like strong ripple effect it's been
very practice one you actually can
change the trajectory of your life this
one alone right but all of these require
practice let me do them right yeah so
you'll never graduate no apparently not
you know and I'm always trying to figure
out what's the next level what's that
level like but men this is a good
foundation how does this dovetail with
with gratitude like you hear about
practicing gratitude which is kind of an
ephemeral concept like how do you
practice gratitude how do you what are
actions that you can take to infuse your
emotional experience with more gratitude
you know what I found is sometimes I
play around rather than love I'll use
other concepts but the same exact
practice and I feel like I you know feel
just like all the magic of life coming
down on me and then when I breathe out
what do you feel naturally when you feel
that gratitude comes out mmm or when you
feel real love what comes out naturally
gratitude I found that gratitude
actually comes up naturally when you're
doing this as a side effect I don't even
have to work on if I work on this yeah I
can see that I'm wondering what it would
be like if you walked around saying if I
was grateful work I'd be happier Larry
it's that's a great question actually
you know what your mental state would be
better I'm sure it would be like these
little simple questions that are you
know we can ask
we should quiet if I was grateful if I
was if I loved myself you know but we
stick with the basic basic foundation
thing suppose what's love gratitude this
fear there's a few things that I just be
just wired for and that's it yeah well
we've been talking for awhile and and I
feel like there's an elephant in the
room because you are here it's kind of a
miracle that you're that you're even
here like that you know there but for
the grace of God go I you just
experienced a very near-death experience
that I think until very recently you
weren't even allowed to travel so I want
to hear that story
and more importantly I want to hear how
that experience has kind of colored how
you think about these practices and what
you wrote in the book and and how its
shaped you know how you how you think
about your life going forward yeah that
is a hell of an elephant yeah
well I was gonna open the podcast and
talk about that but then we just started
talking yeah it's just great rollin I've
gotta love like I think Vera
yeah we started that's how we do it here
I like it it's actually a very
comforting you know there's no and varan
right is it October I went in for a for
for surgery for our old injury I had
being a big fit and active and injured
an artery and and so they went in and
they they fixed it and and then next
morning I was gonna be discharged the
odd but they did the artery burst
basically the stitches hadn't taken and
immediately like boom Elvis and I had a
soccer ball grow in my lower abdomen
really fast and that was blood you know
an artery personal bleeding yeah and but
an artery bursting is a one-way street
you know it's a pressurized system the
[ __ ] hose I delivery one of the hoses
breaks that's it there's no you know
like in a submarine where they shut the
doors kind of thing and it it grew so
big so fast so much pressure that a
burst and it was spraying blood out
spraying blood out where out of my lower
abs so it broke through the skin broke
to the fashion everything like imagine I
mean that's pretty painful I'll tell you
that
but he got the their attention in the
hospital yeah because I've been
complaining about pain and they weren't
giving me any attention and the nurses
startups trying to get more narcotics
and then when I started spraying blood
shoot that I also noticed they're
calling doctors and you know this guy
just wants more drugs and so they
immediately had to bill me into
emergency surgery it was like right away
like boom they were there was a surgery
there was someone going into a surgery
to pull that person out pulling that
because this was literally life or death
I was bleeding out I bled lost so much
blood I remember one guy just trying to
like hold his hands over but trying to
hope just stop the spray you know and
and I remember being in the the are
still been kind of wide awake wide awake
because I was in shock and adrenaline
and all I there was nothing you know no
like
long drawn-out floating towards a light
thing it was just it was flashes of
images of love it was basically images
of love and fear you know images of just
like regret love fear like and and and
fear in a way I've never felt fear
because it was so primal your your body
your mind doesn't know what to do if you
lose blood like that you're watching
your own blood spray area body it very
not designed for that that's not a
normal occurrence usually that results
in death and and springing out of your
abdomen you know like it's not like out
of your arm or something like that
and and I remember the anesthesiologist
and she was leaning over and you know
she everyone had just been rushed and
this was an emergency they all running
and there's like mayhem there moving
things around and and remember these
glasses she wore there were pretty cool
funky glasses and she's like okay I'm
gonna you know put something anyway I
just like pushed it aside and grabbed
her hand and just brought it close I
don't know what it was but as I had to
tell somebody and I was looked at her in
the eyes just kind of like brought in
close I'm like I'm scared and and and
then she what she did was she put her
hand in my hand and something in me
calmed and as something we Fred the two
thoughts went through my head I wasn't
thinking which one thought was what a
shitty messy way did go because here I'm
watching blood spray out people running
out in an or this would be my last
realizing this is my last experience of
life this is my last images I'm seeing
this is not what I would I wanted right
that's one and second realizing I have
no [ __ ] choice and something got very
clear all of a sudden you know like the
images and everything just go away and
it just becomes very clear like I have
no choice and there was a sadness to
that but then that was also like okay
and I remember she hadn't put the IV and
yet she hadn't put the stuff in the area
so this wasn't the drugs had kicked in
because I used to work in a hospital so
there's a part of me that still keeps an
eye on that I'll actually talk to them
about it afterwards too and just feeling
like okay this if this is it this is it
I remember like leaning back and because
I think I'd be sitting trying to sit up
a little bit just from the adrenaline
leaning back of feeling like this image
of I'm falling backwards into the
darkness like like you you know see like
someone falling in an ocean dark ocean
just following forth that's what I felt
like I was just falling falling falling
on let go and that was it that was my
memory and I didn't know you're it
that's it were you conscious the whole
time well and then in that then I could
feel them put something in and then
slowly like I was started because they
had to slash me open yeah it opened you
up suture that find the artery suture
well then but one other thing was I the
surgeon when she came she was she had
come into and I grabbed her hand I was
like look don't make me have gone
through this for nothing
fix fix the thing I came here for she's
like okay how complicated was the
original surgery I mean did they pitch
it to you like this is like kind of a
thing you'll be laid up for a while more
like oh you'll be in and out this is no
big deal
well it was complicated but it was a
very standard micro surgery procedure
this was not exciting yeah were you was
it like the same day in and out or had
you spent that no I would have spent a
day or two but you were getting ready to
be discharged when this happened so
conceivably you could have been in the
Ober on the way home or sitting in your
apartment when this happened yeah if
that was the case that would have been
it you would you would you wouldn't have
made it yeah it was literally like when
I was they were like process getting me
ready to like say okay I'm getting ready
for discharge mmm how much blood do you
lose I don't remember a lot but I
remember the residents saying one of the
red the president I was in the hospital
for a while after that and the residents
the staff became my friends is to come
hang out and talk with me in their off
time and we'd eat together and I said
like Ben you were like gone you'd like
like you'd lost as much as we could let
you and he was just like his freakin
soccer ball just built up so fast Wow
it's insane and that was all blood
and in that like release there's an
acceptance and I guess an even deeper
surrender like a sense of absolute
powerlessness yeah and is there it is
there peace in that I guess in the
moment there was because you have to
because struggle doesn't do anything
right and you realize that is the even
you have no choice right but no white
light no if I the white light
they was felt like my body was was and
was light but everything else was
darkness and it was just falling
backwards that's like the kind of image
I remember but that's almost like a
third-party image so keep in mind I was
also in shock at the time right right
and and I know you're somebody who's
done like a lot of plant medicine and
you know packed into that there are you
know these these experienced these sort
of near-death experiences that you have
or rebirthing and the thing and you know
things of that nature did it bear
resemblance not those experiences matter
dude I've done it all and let me tell
you now I'm okay
actually I feel better I'm actually glad
to hear that I am being hundred percent
honest I'm very experienced in plant
medicine okay
I'm a very curious person I've gone
tried I've done some crazy stuff there
I've experienced what I thought you
could experience not the same not the
same not so does that color how you
think about the value of those
experiences no because I think they
still give you a taste that still make
you better they still make you face
yourself you know I think there are
they're wonderful teachers I highly
recommend him so this experience you end
up in the hospital for quite a while
after that has it altered you know kind
of the things that you say in the book
like how is this shaped how you think
about life going forward well honestly I
have to return to the practice again to
keep myself from just you know I've
spent months writhing in pain you know I
was an insane amount of pain you know
two back-to-back surgeries one a very
aggressive maybe one major surgery and
then 12 or 12 hours later one very
aggressive emergency surgery you know
like you
like the one of the surgeons told me if
anyone qualifies with these narcotics
it's you what cost this was there any
kind of is there an argument for
malpractice here was it just it was you
know her you know what I've thought
about it I'm not a I'm not a litigator
sky everyone does their best but there
were some things that happened and it's
just been the the level of pain I've had
to deal with for so many months you know
I was talking with your wife about this
earlier I have such empathy now for
people who live a chronic pain pain
grinds you down physical pain like
extreme physical pain just grind know
that and so like I've had to do this
work hard just to keep afloat mmm when
I'm in physical pain you know it's like
something to be able to just like get up
and walk across a room and not be
sweating you know like what that takes
you like so I've actually had to go
deeper in this but almost in a survival
way like I am right now an animal and
survival mode and all loving myself is
literally just surviving yeah you're
pain-free now though I'm better their
time so I still deal with it but it's
very manageable I'm getting better the
body is amazing right and I literally
feel like I've been rebuilding my body
you know I'm used to being very fit and
healthy thankfully the surgery they went
the second procedure that did now they
went independent and took a vein out of
my leg like a big thick pipe yeah I put
that in as a big conduit so so at least
if cuz I was like don't make me go
through spirit right if I come out of
this at least we know that artery is
strong now yeah it's better than like I
haven't even made it worse right and and
what's interesting is is is trying to
divine the lesson on all of this right
like we were joking before the podcast
you're like I thought that I'd had I'd
been tested you know I I kind of been
brought to my knees a couple times in my
life and I felt like I'd learned the
lessons and I'm moving in a good
direction did I really need you know do
I really need this to happen haven't I
already had my wake-up moment like why
this why now I'll be honest man this
this brought me to my knees in a way
I've never
I struggle at times it's like almost
left why am I here I don't unspecial II
when you're in pain your mind goes there
right I'm still struggling with it and
I'm so grateful that so I turn in the
final final master of this book I think
a week before I went into surgery right
and and now this book comes out and this
is a book I so care about you know I
have such an obligation to the readers
you know who emails me and who gave me
the cushions that to put this out to the
world that that's the thing I get up for
like that's why I got on a plane and
came to LA to see you is to share this
book you know it's uh it's like I gave
myself this gift before going to
experience I don't know if I had didn't
have this book what I would have done
mm-hmm honestly it's like a it's it's
something that's bigger than me that's
more important I mean that'll make me
get on that plane when if I'm feeling
pain I would get on a pain and come and
share the book that that's been a great
gift I don't know where I'd be if I
didn't have it yeah and secondly because
have the book I read it right and
sometimes you know I wrote this for
myself and and so so there are moments
in life where it's a practice like this
could literally just make you survive
and sometimes that's all you can do you
know you're just assumed it's it's very
interesting that's something I just
realized the other day because I've been
beating myself up for for being like
closed off from everyone and just being
curled up in pain and was like dude your
survival mode yeah it's okay
nobody's expecting me going on the talk
show circuit you just got out of the
hospital um like I mean I got a hospital
in October but you know I couldn't wait
to get out it was like the first one
they say you might be out I was like
damn things worse place to be if you're
not feeling well is a hospital really it
is be worst place on the planet all your
dignity is gone you've been poked and
prodded 24/7 you know just and that's
where a lot of the germs are anyway yeah
right but it's interesting that after
all of this you're still beating
yourself up measuring yourself against
some standard that that nobody else is
applying to you
well I have to do the self forgiveness
practice again don't I mm-hmm yeah yeah
we all yeah that's that's an interesting
thing I'm realizing that I need to do
some of this stuff that more that
practice more often than I thought
mm-hmm
you know I'm learning the stuff myself
you know I'm still evolving it myself
and it's it's very interesting I've had
to go back to it but in a very different
way and now that I'm getting better I'm
very curious to see if what the effects
are still doing it will be yeah and I
think there is there is a deeper lesson
and what you just experienced I think
you just need time and distance from it
before that becomes evident or clear but
I think I think more will be revealed I
I think that's something will come out
of that that will that you will then
realize is an opportunity I hope so you
know I I was I believe if you go through
something there's a there's something
good that a gift that comes out of it
but it's up to us to find that gift
right I mean one of the things you talk
about is this idea of of inverting the
idea that things are happening to you
and looking at it from the perspective
of you happening to things or maybe even
another corollary to that is things are
happening for you yeah yeah that one's
been hard for this experience yeah you
know I think maybe it might be who had
become because of it you know who I
choose to be as I rebuild myself who
I've become
we'll see yeah well I I can't imagine
that you you came out of it and you must
have come out of this thinking life is
even more precious than I real you know
previously appreciated and that time is
short and we don't know how long we're
gonna be here and you know if you have a
message that you feel strongly about
like now is the time to you know give
your all to what is most important to
you yeah I mean I'm lucky I have it you
know but putting this book out it's
interesting the thing about precious
some of those it's weird because time
still goes by slips by and I find you
know we fall back into our way of living
which is just like you know often
wasting time
the mind is very interesting how it
quickly forgets lessons and one has to
be constantly reminded what I'd like to
do is I'd like to remind myself of
feeling just feeling life feeling
blessed by a life sometimes because I
have to look at that being surviving no
matter what I went through is a blessing
there has to be a blessing in there and
what does that look like like what is
the actual practice so I do the same
thing as I do with the ten breasts
except now that life becomes a blessings
huh
I like that I like that it's so simple
and practical you know it's not it's
there's not a lot of you know in the
book there's no window dressing around
anything woowoo it's like this is what I
did feel so much better and here's how
you do it it'll take you five minutes
you know I get a lot of emails from
people who say like what made them use
the book or what made them share it was
the fact they could tell it was just a
guy just a dude who wrote it who did it
yeah yeah yeah I listened to the podcast
that you did with Jonathan fields and he
he put you he put the question to you
like given that you had had an interest
in in in fiction writing like why not
make this a parable this book rather
than making it a practical primer doing
some storytelling you know in an in a
fiction setting I don't remember what I
said to him but what comes to mind now
is because for something like this you
just need the simple truth straight to
the fact this works this is how it works
this is what to do I think what you also
said to him was that that it's the
honesty like the personal honesty and
accountability was what in your in your
belief was was what made it connect with
people yeah it's amazing people are
readers are wonderful you know just how
they reach out they give you more than
you give me and I feel like you give so
are you still like a Silicon Valley poor
you live in San Francisco right but are
you still alive you see and all that are
you just full-on I mean work these days
you are you're in New York
okay yeah it was a long flight to come
see I thought you came from San
Francisco I didn't realize wow my flight
was to the mercial hours of a full
cross-country totally worth it I have a
thank you know I wrote a VC firm that I
built on my own after I had lost
everything and I rebuilt myself and so I
invest in tech startups and the writings
what I realized is what I've learned is
planning for and that's that's the thing
that I want to leave behind right you
know these books but yeah I enjoy I love
working with like I advise some
companies and Western companies it keeps
that part of my brain active right you
know and and I actually enjoy it you you
know you get to work with people
building the future you know it's it's
fun yeah all right well you gotta write
about what just happened you think so
yeah but I don't have a there's no
lesson there well maybe it's not it's
not yet time to write about it but at
some point I I think that there will be
a lot that comes out of that and like I
said earlier I think I think it will be
revealed to you but at some point you're
gonna I think it's gonna be important
that you're right about that
okay what else are you what else are you
working on that's the thing that's one
thing I'm struggling I have nothing
I've tried writing and there's nothing
that's coming out that's inspiring me
right you know you're in your gestation
period so I'm reading a lot mmm I've
actually been reading a lot of physics
and and quantum physics and just dying a
rabbit hole in nature reality is
interesting
yeah just like okay look at look at
Stephen Hawking's paper and this and
that like what is you know the smart
guys they're really smart it's their
interpretation the nature of reality
I've been really fascinated by that so
I'm just kind of like by not feeding my
curiosity about these things
uh-huh is there like an approach that
you take towards trying to decide what
to read or is it just your muse it's my
muse is the Internet's you know you this
rabbit holes reddit is amazing you can
find an expert in everything or someone
who thinks they're an expert and
everything is I'm also been working on
okay what is mine what is a practical
philosophy of life I want to live by
after all that I began to give been
through what is something that that I
can actually live and this is the
philosophy I've been working on
practically and I'm not suggesting this
for anyone so I don't please people
don't send many emails about you know
the flaws in it it's literally something
I'm trying to do which is I am the cause
of everything in my life because when I
do that it's all personal responsibility
there's no victim there's no there's no
feeling sorry for myself there's only
choice everything that has happened in
my life because look the nature of
reality if you were to really bring it
down is that there is no reality we
don't know what the whole show is but
then there's this whole 3d dimensional
you know thing there's more to this game
than that reality I'm with man we know
that yeah so then okay if that's the
case you talk to my wife yeah she's
awesome
I love your wife by the way police
people order her cheese it's out of this
world I mean you know she's she's
functioning on in multiple reality
simultaneously I think but go ahead yeah
so I've been thinking like look what but
how do I my whole thing is how do I
practically live something I don't want
to just theory I want to be better
because of it so I'm like look if
there's this underlying layer and
somehow we're just I'm a part of him
connected it's like consciousness let's
say it's all consciousness and that's
the ocean I'm just a wave in the ocean
that blip comes and goes that almost the
way we almost went but stay always still
in the ocean all right what is the way I
can live that somehow almost frees me
but also gives me forward momentum
because if it's always choice then it's
in your control so I am the cause of
everything I've been actually looking
I'm the cause of that experience of the
surgery I'm the cause of good things
happening to me I'm the cause of bad
things happening I'm the cause of it all
so what do I do
so that's a personal philosophy I've
been kind of working on myself and just
trying to mentally do it where
everything I go through I am the cause
of this not that I made you appear out
of thin air in a ritual but more like my
experience of light no I get that I mean
I think it's a it's a spiritual bent on
a on a very Goggins esque idea you know
oh yeah just sort of unbridled absolute
responsibility for everything in your
life and you know never never blaming
anyone and I think when you're when
you're of that mindset and you approach
and navigate life in that way it's
impossible to be a victim right because
if you're taking responsibility
everything that happens to you good or
bad or taking responsibility and
ownership for you know every conflict
that you find yourself in then you
become an actor rather than a reactor
you become the hero rather than the
victim and you're presented with
opportunity rather than dead ends I
think right you know and I'll tell you
it's not easy to live this in your head
because the mind repels the mind wants
to find cause outside yourself sure it's
so that's what the whole who doesn't who
does want to point the finger right you
know so it's almost like a little mental
training I'm doing for myself so that's
kind of like a new thing I'm working on
just cabal so welcome to Kamal's world
right well I know I think that I think
that that's I mean that's a it's a
harder thing I think to practice then
repeating I love myself we're doing the
mirror work you know because it's it
gets harder and and I found and this is
you know for me it always goes back to
12 steps this is another thing I learned
that like even when I find myself in a
conflict with somebody else where it's
clear that I've been wronged and
everybody that I talked to about this
thing will all agree with me that I am
the victim this person wronged me
there's no gray area here always always
if I'm honest with myself I can find my
part in in in how that situation or that
dynamic was created and I think taking
ownership of that allows you to
transcend that victim mentality and also
provides the opportunity for self
forgiveness and forgiveness of the other
person so that you can yeah release
surrender and free yourself from
whatever pain or emotional weight that
that you know that that that forces you
to carry around yeah I think it can be
very powerful yeah but it's hard yeah I
know how are you doing with it depends
on the moment in the day but I'll tell
you but like even doing the love
yourself practice I do it because if I'm
the cause I have to work in my inside
uh-huh
if Who I am is the cause of my
experience of life that it then I have a
responsibility working inside because if
I don't
and I'll be the cause of shitty things
yeah another thing I wanted to talk to
you about is is honoring the child
within right as somebody who I mean you
you've endured a you know a fair amount
of childhood trauma
it's easy to fall into victimhood over
that as well right yeah
and it's and it's the kind of the more
you evolve and grow the more you realize
that you loop patterns and tell stories
that were formed from that childhood
experience that then show up in in in in
behavior patterns and in adult life that
don't serve you and yet you feel
powerless to kind of snap out of them
yeah that is yes all our facts yeah so
but you kind of have a practice around
how you how you kind of talk to the
inner child or or honor that young
person inside of you yeah and it all
comes from this this practice of what I
do is I take the founded this practice
the foundation approach different parts
of me in my life through this lens and
you know the first time I did it I
remember something shifted because I
realized something about the child you
know I was used to be ashamed of what
the child went through you know it was I
was ashamed or dirty at this and that I
was wounded I was tainted like these
things I overcame them right but I was
ashamed of what the child of the
experience of the charm and when I did
the sex of the first time it's
interesting when you do these your
perspective shifts you know and like if
your perspective shifts everything
shifts and if I was no dumbass it's good
well I had no dumbass this child
survived - so you could be you this
child went through this I mean think of
the strength it takes to be a child you
know and go through things and continue
on and not quit and keep on working -
like one day I'll get out of this one
day I'll be better one day I'll get out
of this one day no one will screw with
Bobo whatever right but that child
deserves medals mmm you know nothing
like keep the Trident and it was like oh
my god it was a huge perspective shift
and it was a game changer where like
you're grateful for the child
or having the stray you you don't think
of a child as having strength you
realize the strength it takes to be a
child and adore abuse that's insane
yeah alright and so like now I just feel
so much gratitude and gratitude to this
child like thank you for for your
strength you know I'd never realized
that before until I did this right I
like that I mean that's that's a very
cool practice and way to think about
that wounding you know what I mean when
you think about the experience of a
child even a child that grows up in a
healthy environment a young child in the
period of 24 hours will throw a couple
tantrums cry a bunch dines be frustrated
feel angry because they can't
communicate their idea or whatever idea
they're trying to communicate isn't
landing right like the emotional turmoil
of a childhood experience even under the
best circumstances is incredibly
challenging when you think about it like
they go through more emotional turmoil
in a day than I certainly do right so
the strength the capacity of a young
person to you know weather so much it
seems obvious that we should honor that
yeah you know yeah it's kind of it's
very interesting I mentioned to other
people and it's actually caused that
shift of them to I find out I'm not the
only one who was that way about his
childhood uh-huh you know when you come
from a traumatic childhood you kind of
like want to put it on the rug you're
like I got over it
right okay that's how fast I'm done one
yeah I overcame it I got over it I'm
fine right whatever but honoring that
child who made it happen who had the
strength you know that's special mm-hmm
I think that's a good place to end it
love yourself like your life depends on
it
what what is like you know just to kind
of close this down for somebody who's
listening to this who feels stuck or or
perhaps finds themself in a in a
situation that they can't see their way
out of give that person a starting point
starting point look what did it for me
was making a commitment
myself you know and first deciding that
look I'm gonna keep commitments to
myself right but if you make a vow to
yourself if you're ever in a place where
you just need to get out of the make up
vow to you so I'll write it down but
it's somewhere you can see it every day
we're reminded of your act here so your
promise to yourself and then do your
best to live it you'll fail horribly
every day but you'll get better and
better do your best to live it every day
it's really that simple that power of
that personal commitment to yourself
yeah
it's that simple and you don't have to
you know lose your company and all your
get left by you know your one love in
order for you to take advantage of that
right that's the important thing like
you know a lot of people's elevators are
going down they don't realize that they
can get off every you know at any moment
they have to experience that bottom and
that wake-up call is required or
necessary to get that person's attention
but the truth is these tools are
powerful and transformative and
available to you you know wherever and
whenever you find yourself yeah it's the
human mind I know well thank you for
sharing oh man this was so were saying
it thank you I love the book like I said
it's it's not only packed with these
amazing transformational practices but
it's super easy to read and enjoy like
you can you can literally you know read
the whole thing in an afternoon it's
very easy to digest so I appreciate that
and that doesn't come easily 10,000
hours right yeah yeah that's craft so
thank you thank you for the book I think
it's a I think it's a gift and I think
you're a gift to humanity and I
appreciate the work that you do my
friend thank you so come back and talk
to me anytime you can find the book at
your favorite independent bookseller or
on Amazon mm-hmm you can find kemal on
twitter at Kamal rava Kampf but he will
not follow you back because he only
follows one person the rock what is that
about well if you read the book I
understand yeah where else can people
find out Twitter Instagram the usuals
you know but just my email address is
also in this book yeah email me right
but you know email me you respond to all
the emails I do sometimes it takes a
does that get back locked I always do
people are really good sometimes you'll
find someone who just has an axe to
grind and you just happen to be the one
they want to do it
polite respond and end it but most
people I've made friends with readers
like people like considered good friends
who reach out to we just start having
conversations you know it's amazing yeah
that's cool man
well I'm gonna be in New York this
spring can we go grab dinner kind of
would love it James and well I'll go out
for a bite
I would love some vegan food yes sir
okay thanks man
all right that's it thank you come on
appreciate you peace dude this is the
best interview I've had this is the best
yeah like I can't wait like that's the
title of the podcast now come all rava
cappa
the best interviewing kid he's ever had
[Music]